j'habite encore chez mes parents ce qui
est pas seulement bidon mais très triste
par contre je fais une émission sur le
calque et kaboom question d'école je
suis pas dernier mais la seule chose
dont je rêve ce serait qu'on le paye
pour mon émission ce pur arrive je
pourrais arriver à chier par l'apm
[Musique]
khartoum aviv
c'est mon meilleur pote kartal garde
salut
c'est l'heure de bohemian rhapsody les
amis génial way
haïti est le dos et le water
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
gabriella bonsoir ça va bonsoir bâti
très bien en important non non non c'est
parfait moi je suis je suis venu à pied
que je sais pas conduire donc je ne vais
je ne dîne que la houlette de la faisant
forme l'écoutent oui je reviens de
suisse j'ai respiré bonnaire des
montagnes dans une clinique dans un
hôtel simplement chez mon ami cambuzat
ah oui oui je vais de temps en temps des
intoxiqués chez cambuzat non j'avais une
guinée qui souhaite un bon hôtel c'est
tout je te rassure ça marche on ne voit
pas trop quand même à la télé ben non
mais tu sais moi je lundi j'ai refusé
d'aller à une émission de
dechavanne s'est pas du tout aux côtés
de sharon c'est c'était une émission tu
sais effet une nouvelle émission n'avait
fait ni sur la corse que j'avais vu en
suisse d'ailleurs les gens seuls et là
c'est une émission sur le retour de
l'ordre moral est alors au départ
j'étais censé faire partie des dix ont
des libertins et alors d'un côté il y
aurait eu les gens pour l'ordre dans
l'ordre la morale est en moi j'étais
censé parler contre la morale est une
chose et ça j'ai replongé
c'est le principe que je refuse déjà
qu'on nous met une étiquette sur le dos
moi je souffre on comptera beaucoup de
cette étiquette du libertin peu moins d
agir absolument rien dire moi je peux
être je suis aussi peut-être je voudrais
bien venir dans une mission parler de
morale mais sans qu'on préjuge donc
quand je serai déjà c'est tu sais il ya
des étiquettes spécialement à voile à 80
alors on va bosser c'est beaucoup isa m
magicienne voilà on va goûter attention
mais ça doit être dur à la télé
aujourd'hui pour trouver des gens qui
veulent venir un carmel et les amoureux
ça je ne sais pas mais il avoir du mal
parce qu'il ya on est en plein dans leur
moral donc c'est sûr que pour trouver
quelqu'un qui veut venir jouer contre
les moralistes ça c'était difficile
ce qu'est ce qui est l'ennui la
télévision c'est qu'elles n'ont pas la
télévision de météores j'ai peut-être
des médias en général c'est que tu n'as
pas vraiment souvent le temps de
l'expliquer et que très vite le public a
de toi une image qui peut me ciel si
elle est caricatural ici ensuite le mois
après certaines émissions notamment je
pense d'un pivot 20 des derniers
apostrophe tu vois et bien ensuite
j'ai eu des ennuis même de gens qui
montent apostrophe dans la rue des
choses comme ça moi je préfère ma vie
privée et ma tranquillité à la
littérature j'aime bien littérature mais
je vais pas commencer à avoir des
accrochages avec avec des dames très
très bon chic bon genre dans les
magasins les lots a par exemple qui me
gêne monsieur tu vois des trucs
mais jeudi mme hamm qui avait voulu de
moi mais c'est ce qu'a fait alors dans
ce cas là adressez vous à adresser la
parole à des écrivains que vous avez lu
écouté qu'est ce que c'est mais je vous
ai vu à la télévision mais [ __ ] écrit
là c'est pas la télévision un écrivain
c'est libre enfin mais tant que bon
temps dans une société normale c'est pas
grave on s'en fout mais maintenant il ya
une espèce d'hystérie général et donc à
ce moment là il faut être un peu prudent
parce que tu te dis que tu n'as pas
envie de le bouc émissaire de je ne sais
quelle campagne ou de je ne sais quel
l'esprit des fans siècle sont
spécialement bête
ouais écoute la fin du xviiie
robespierre qui coupe les têtes au nom
de la vertu les libertins les athées
tout le monde on coupe les têtes c'est
la vertu c'est vraiment la fin du 19ème
oscar wilde à reading dreyfus à l'île du
diable la vertu aussi n'est ce pas et
maintenant la fin du xxème siècle entre
monsieur alors il ya eu reagan
il ya eu comme eni n'y a eu en bonne 2
et le sida en a même en 4 fléau qui ont
rendu le monde fou voilà c'est prêt mais
simple on est prêt pour les champignons
enfin pas de champignons qui allait avec
un tissu que les tomates des oignons
confits
merci justement dans ce monastère ggg
cueillir des champignons mais sans
certainement bwana bien moins bien
accommodée par les moines que par isaac
mais c'est normal que les gens aient du
mal à comprendre admettre que tu puisses
être à la fois écrivain disons sulfureux
tués en même temps où tu as envie de te
retirer dans des dans des monastères et
ses villages in pour les gens c'est des
gens il m'a tout ou dans des cases
q med et cédric est surtout donc place à
l'est mais je crois moi quand je leur
dis que je suis royaliste et que c'est
une des pétards pour eux il ya ceux qui
fument des pétards y avait quelque chose
c'est une race qui n'existe pas donc
c'est pareil ils ne connaissent pas bien
l'histoire la monarchie sans star mais
en fait moi je je je pense que tout le
monde est pétri de contradictions mais
seuls les artistes les exprime si nous
étions seuls les artistes ont vivent
seuls les artistes en vivent et sont
nourris si je puis dire
donc on avait
il faut commencer à écrire à quel âge et
coûte en fait je donc j'écris comme tout
le monde à 13 14 ans des petits trucs
que je pense même des poèmes les choses
comme ça mais je me vois me mettre au
fond ce que le déclic il ya du moulin
pointe un peu de poivre
le déclic ça a été ça a été quand j'ai
commencé à tenir mon journal mon journal
intime des recalages 16 en saison une
saison et demie dans ma 17e année il se
raconter quoi d amour non non non gt1 et
pudique
j'étais en plus de ça un mois j'étais un
adolescent plutôt chaste montre est seul
et très révolté d'entrée suicidaire très
très tournante et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'ai commencé à écrire
mon journal quand je me suis senti prêt
c'est le journal c'est le confident way
qui on dit des choses qu'on ne dirait
pas son meilleur ami cre voilà bien
lifté le défi non le défi c'est quoi
c'était en 65 ça va juste être un temps
meilleur je fête mes pieds 30 ans de vie
littéraire ce qui fait un peu hein
ce qui ne nous rajeunit pas moins mais
c'est bien quand même
quand on entend de vie littéraire et au
fond
moi je pense qu'on récré toujours le
même livre je voudrais expliquer au
public c'est moi si j'avais une émission
littéraire dispositif au public que les
sujets ne sont en rien que les tous les
sujets c'est la page de france soir le
rachat de france et les faits divers de
parisiens une verrue en soi parce que tu
veux les sujets appartient à tout le
monde un sujet c'est rien ce qui fait le
skiff et les le livre c'est le tout
c'est la patte propre de l'artiste
définit ya pas de bons sujets de notre
sujet connaissant l'intérêt total des
centres d'intérêts effectivement je
parlais du suicide tue près d'une île il
ya les amours adolescentes des ans
c'est quand même une grande âme il ya
des thèmes ses succès sur les jeux
d'hier c'est m en soi comment dirais je
c'était mon choix ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé thèmes qui sont intéressants
c'est la façon dont on les traite
notons en fait ce qui t'arrive
aujourd'hui c'est comme tu t'es
intéresser beaucoup à des amants à des
amendes jeunes le
aujourd'hui on ne retient que ça on
retient pas le style dans lequel ça a
été fait c'est ce que dit on retient le
sujet plus que le plus que le traitement
final 38 les sujets les sujets ont connu
les sujets encore si c'est les gens qui
me critiquent avait la gentillesse de
lire les livres appartenant
il dirait que dans ses romans où
effectivement les héroïnes
les héroïnes sont très jeunes ont des
romans d'amour ou des passions partagées
et c'est l'analyse de la patience et
l'étude de la passion et la description
de la passion que je crois est belle il
donne un exemple je peux le dire parce
que cette jeune fille vanessa je les
rencontre a t elle m'a inspiré un roman
harrison plaza c'est là qu'on s'était vu
des jeunes interviewés pour l'année et
ensuite un tome de journal intime qui
vient de paraître en folio
il s'appelle lui la prunelle de mes yeux
mais c'est la même gêne personne qui me
l'a inspiré eh bien j'ai rencontré
vanessa dans un dîner chez ma directrice
littéraire
[Musique]
il lancé
et
oh
mon levine et des rôles intéressants
[Musique]
m
je
faux
donc
[Musique]
on
il va maintenant
m
non
on
[Musique]
non
faux je ne suis devenu son amant nylon
de diamants que plusieurs mois plus tard
on avait 14 ans c'est pas un je veux
dire je veux dire que ça a été une
complète près dans une tête réciproque
qui veut dire que le jour les adhésifs
chez moi elle avait aussi envie témoin
que depuis vision telle chute récente et
ensuite quand j'ai été dénoncé je dire
être un all in
y'a pas que il ya eu des les fans ainsi
qu'à en france est une grande ambition
est d'être anonyme des milieux
d'ailleurs guy ferrer les lettres
anonymes et maintenant les amis de ses
parents parce que la mère avait la rage
et comment la mère a respecté la passion
la mer du nord aurait dû intervenir
elle a compris que c'était une véritable
passion réciproque sa fidélité
gabrielle simon avec l âge avec moi
j'avais j'avais quarante neuf ans et je
dois dire que j'ai fêté mes j'ai des
traits des prix des légumes par exemple
effrayant d'avoir 50 ans imagine dans
les romans de dostoïevski
on dit que le vieux car à mes yeux un
vieux 45 contre hors de moi
il ya j'ai vécu m'auditionner au mois
d'aout qui viennent je suis
nous sommes devenus amants vanessa et
moi au mois de début de l'été en fin du
printemps début de l'été j'ai vécu la
nuit usagers de mes 50 ans la journée on
apprenait restés 48 heures au lit dans
les bras l'un de l'autre
j'étais absolument merveilleux de passer
ces demi siècle dans les bras d'une
sublime beauté 14 ans garçons on dirait
bien vanessa était prête
j'ai été dénoncée j'étais retourné la
nsa était prête à revoir
françois mitterrand dont dix ans je
laime je vais l'épouser si on m'avait
envoyé en prison qu'elle n'était pas
sûre cet amour et donc c'est ça que 6 me
respecte comme je sais wella gillette
tutu a gardé de tout garder relations
après on va pas avec vanessa s'est rangé
on s'est revus parfois mais c'est trop
dur notre moi je deviens blanche en
lessive
non
maintenant on est là
trois ans maintenant
mais je si j'apprenais de magalas besoin
de moi je
est ce que quand il ya une telle
différence d'âge est ce que ça ne lit
pas les sexes est ce qu'on peut pas
quand on a un certain âge qu'on ait des
relations avec des gens beaucoup plus
jeune
est ce que finalement au bout d'un
moment ça devient pas assez indifférente
ceux des filles et des garçons toutes
mes grandes passions n'ont été
on était des filles un moment de ma vie
mais je dois dire que c'est un grand
moment pour moi le passé un moment de ma
vie mais quand j'étais très jeune
justement tu vois c'est l'équipe avec la
victoire c'est plutôt congelés
17 18 19 ans j'étais très sensible aux
charmes des jeunes garçons intérieur
dans mon schéma de l'adolescence qui a
paru en librairie il ya c'est vrai il ya
plus de jeunes garçons que de filles
non je veux dire que celui
je pense que bon
mon journal ni roman est douloureuse
mais le livre coûte émirats le crous en
ma faveur et ça je les dis votre langue
gallimard retrouver c'est un recueil les
lettres d'amour que ces jeunes filles
ont écrit sur pn ça je pense que si ce
livre qui paraît être après ma mort mais
si on peut faire ce livre
moi je n'ai pas de passe et ça serait
des plus beaux ça serait moins 80 des
habitants d'absolution parce que non
seulement j'en dernier parce que ce soit
des gens disent oui votre innovantes cfi
n'existe parfois il a fallu 3 soit il
les a rendus très malheureux ce soir
c'est soldats abusé l'être quand jeune
fille décrit comme un délai de passion
et d'amour
cependant trois ou quatre ans même 200 m
cinq ans ou même plus
c'est quand même donc ça fait un
ensemble et ça sera des très belles est
parce qu'en plus de ça il ya une
génialité d'adolescence surtout pour les
femmes nous restons géniaux gourou bilan
mais mais mais c'est vrai ces derniers
s'est pas mise au lit ce que je dis je
ne voudrais pas que ç'a paru misogyne
des portois d un petit peu mais
c'est qu'il ya une géniale chez les
adolescentes qui qui se perd lorsqu'elle
entre dans l'âge adulte et je vais dire
pourquoi c'est parce que ces
adolescentes ont été géniales dans quel
était rebelle ou notamment par des
contres mais enfin des enfants mais un
jeu un jour elles sont récupérées les
maires des jeux pour écrire mourani de
la ville sur les maires sur les mairies
sur les relations utiles et les maires
et quand quelque chose de très
importantes très fort avec une fille
si leurs trésors qui est tout à fait ton
côté conservé par exemple en toi même tu
te dis un jour c'est la mère qui
l'emportera il reviendra vers sa mère et
son aile
et les maires gagnent que je n'en suis
pas une époque très drôle non mais nous
ne tue c'est il faut être supérieures à
son époque s'il faut pas non plus
laisser démoraliser
moi je trouve qu on les emmerde à pied à
cheval en bois qui me déplaisait pas
c'est vrai quand on a connu
sans être nostalgique mais c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque j'étais beaucoup plus
jeune que moi donc beaucoup
je m imagine john j'aime l'art les
icônes et les visages de jeunes filles
et bien de même j'aime cette cuisine ou
y ait du soleil
c'est cette espèce de mélange de cette
utilisation
à partir des cuisines très classique
française par la haute école de la
cuisine
mélanger des aromates des saveurs v30
baudelairienne travaux frédéric magnus
frédéric housse magnus écoutez je suis
très fier
l'interrompt de cette conversation mais
c'est quand même
en fait c'est une émission sur les sur
les coiffeurs m'assoyais les coupes de
cheveux minima est toujours là parce
qu'on fait si tu le sais on fume plus
non et bien m'excuser avant et après oui
ça tiens ça c'est ça c'est beaucoup plus
difficile
et puis surtout car moi ce matin j'étais
alors votre honneur messieurs je suis
allé chez j'avais tous les huit jours
toi tu peux y aller une fois par an ça
suffit non moi je suis pro b messieurs
mais non tous mes droits d'auteur pas
son coiffeur c'est que ce vin ou le
souhaiterez curé l'on s'est assuré du
château chalon on dirait du cross à
l'entrée mort après avoir autre chose
que du sincère design me fila d'eric
avec mes lacets laviolette 6 milliards
violet mais moi je voudrais un truc dans
un verre genre il poivre un truc comme
ça tu avais déjà dit n'est vraiment dans
un va faire ça merci de ma caisse je
sais que je le regretterai non mais
c'est vrai je suis très ému de voir
gabriel à chaque fois que je vois je
suis ému parce que quand j'ai publié mon
premier roman à la table ronde il était
là il avait même écrit la quatrième de
couv je me souviens j'ai toujours admiré
parce que plupart des mots on va pas
faire comme c'est une émission qui est
différent des autres on va pas faire du
lèche vitrine mais c'est juste une
parenthèse parce qu'ils trient
traditionnels vers des skis très moderne
mais je laisse est vrai que dans la
merde actuelle d'un milieu des lettres
complètement pourri
les magouilles et s'est garé là tout
était toujours d'intégrer pas incroyable
le bouquin qui sort l'a donc vous avez
déjà dû parler par léon l'apparition
plus intéressant que deux internats
c'est un recueil d'articles alors tous
les titres qui écrit des articles
quand on lit les articles de nous russie
et compagnie c'est bâclé c'est mal écrit
et bien alors que
je suis que nos métiers on pourrait
citer plein de gens j'ai envie de me
griller comme jean ce soir à saint
geours bon c'est ça qui est incroyable
qui soigne le style toujours toujours
même dans le moindre petit truc que
personne ne va lire dans une frangine de
province dans le sud un des trucs
prestigieux y soit une écriture et sarah
respect respect varès 10 et là à propos
de ses chroniques
la réput la réputation du chocolat
menier est dû à sa qualité toujours
égale il sait qu'un écrivain depuis même
dans une petite chronique d'un journal
d'étudiants et dans une page de romance
contrôle de qualité label matney alors
là il ya de la cocaïne
ils ont mis deux un truc sur le nom
c'est un truc pour toi tiens prends ça
je sais tiens prends ça tu vas voir
c'est un truc qui va me faire aller au
chien ça va bien je prends avec le
château st merci beaucoup
ça me touche beaucoup enfin il a compris
ce que si vous voulez profiter nous
embête que son adversaire mais j'en ai
un pour moi j'arrive de six mois j'en
prends aussi un porte- montrer à quel
point
mais il faut expliquer ce qu'il sait et
attend est-ce que c'est du cloud mal
atterri dire ça je veux pas dire ce que
c'est un acte évident c'est que même sur
le câble ont expliqué tu veux aller là
ce soir je te pose la question à toi
puisque et brive est insomniaque mais
pas découragé après ses deux ans et demi
et nous on va aller voir des buts de 62
ans
c'est pourquoi mon frère aîné richard
des gamines de 12 ans et demi et lui
dirai avec des noms ce que je ne sais
pas si c'est moi je te suis là c'est toi
c'est ta tournée un son tout a déjà été
écrit peu rien n'a d'intérêt peut-être
[Rires]
attentionné vraiment inspiré en mieux
vérifier alors c'est bon c'est légal au
moins donc ça va on peut les diffuser le
sucre glace
on construit autant pas pour longtemps
tue c'est pire est passé
tu t'es passé dans une autre bonne
émission des bonnes minutes
j'avais bu par l'oreille ouais souvient
au début par laurel comme quoi les
seules fois où je fais les choses
brillantes c'est quand il ya thierry à
la table un métier stimulant
entre temps une dix années se sont
écoulées oui et j'ai rien fait
d'intéressantes le dizaines
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya là et pourquoi il
cesse ce n'est qu'un début continuons le
combat
ce n'est qu'un début continuons le
révolution qu'est-ce qu'il ya ma poule
ils ont plein droit de chanter c'est ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce qui se passe ben voilà messieurs
voilà c'est quand vous de montrer enfin
cela fait plaisir
depuis tout côtoie la terre que la saint
michel les cieux si sa passe ratée
l'évidence nous fera vachement plaisir
pour nos musiciens avec elle si la
police n'a pas le droit de jouer
pourquoi votre cher monsieur le maire de
paris nous interdit tiberi il veut pas
qu'on joue à la percu il dérange tout le
monde on a pas de recours quoi que ce
soit alors on espère qu'on vous soir un
geste en berne ou un endroit où je sais
qu'on peut jouer de la musique en
permanence cette semaine à paris 80 cas
des canadiennes et des canadiens est ce
que vous avez du canadien avec vous
ouais les dix mecs pour 91 ans
[Musique]
jouer était tranquille l'a toujours été
même avis
tiens un van de graaf
vous avez un local
[Musique]
aux gens à quel agissent pour calculer
pour la première fois c'est moi et vous
c'est à quel âge
hahaha
pour me la faire
le
alors
[Musique]
beauté
passer en force mais truc sans y aller
8 parce que moi je pensais que si on
allait là c'était pour aller voir des
films et des trucs parce que là si
c'était pour battant la chine fournit
pas à temps c'est ici que ces trucs là
moi j'y vais jose parents créent une
fois que je peux rentrer n'attendez pas
de vengeance pas rentrer cette alerte
rouge et non
[Musique]
ça ma mère
on va vers un hasard à
oui
m
et angeline et vous là à ce moment il à
l'insolent à barcelone à bon port en
même temps
by revenir à 20 personnes a fini sur
l'un des chemins ouais j'ai fidèles
ouais c'est ça
les seuils qui arrive oui je trompe
souvent bon c'est aïcha arrêteront plein
toutes les garçons je trouve la nar
je trouverais même pas banal
bah oui place
on tremble jamais
non oui dans mes fantasmes avec itunes
trompe-t-on jours
c'est la victoire
mais lui c'est un hardeur moi je suis
pas ardeurs serait beaucoup trompé
forcément avec une arme non j'imagine
que quand on a l'habitude de faire
l'amour avec ardeur c'était vachement
difficile à non pas du tout goûté mardi
d'abord merci
c'est quoi ça a dit moi c'est quoi je
suis déçu c'est qui
ça y est le même le soit pas
c'est très bien
non même en fait les mecs doivent pas
osé te draguer parce que comme ils
savent que tu es avec ardeur ils ont
peur d'être ils ont peur d'être en
dessous non mais non c'est ce fait parce
qu'un ardeur et c'est une pièce et
humains comme nous apporter entre la
maison et fait l'amour pour mon comme
toi tu peux faire l'amour dont je ne
sais pas
mais pour l'équipe quantité d'amour avec
ton ardeur c'est pas c'est pas con dans
la chimie a pas des positions et on
s'imagine côté chez toi avec roberto ça
doit être comme un [ __ ] être comme au
cinéma on avait entre 5 et 8 ans je
pense que je serai doctor who qui te
fais des trucs normaux ou tiéné truc que
tout le monde fait quoi du moment les
positions dans les films se trompent pas
agréable ah ouais
et bien moi je préfère dans le lit ou et
c'est plus agréable mais sur mon dos à
la latendresse normal
ouais comme un comme un couple normal
oui voilà c'est vrai oui c'est vrai tu
me le jure et chaussures
un peu d'alcool c'est parce que ces
jeunes je n'arrive pas à comprendre ce
que je ressens pas la loi mais c'est
vachement beau jeu parce que c'est
bizarre on dirait du on dirait du slime
ça le truc vert avoir un truc avec de
l'alcool
qu'est-ce qui t'excite alors qu'est ce
qui n'existe plus à part moi tu bois
alors dit moi
merci à ses dépens dans ce département
des bornes peut avoir du mur que je vais
être la petite victoire étriquée mexique
comme ça
va voir est
[Musique]
car si ça passe à se désabonner mariage
en défens table par exemple cet excité
de faire sauter par plant de maïs avec
ben j'ai jamais si jamais
quand je suis plusieurs mecs me crame
suffisamment vite beaucoup m'afflige un
mec ce mec est une fille c'est à dire à
trois avec une fille
avec une fille aussi tu fais ça tu
arrives étonnamment avec dépit ça te
plait ça
bon on y va on va danser envie de
rentrer dans la boîte avait dansé dans
cela mais bon pas
je te fais la cuisine alors à j'adore
d'habitat première expérience sexuelle à
quel âge
compénétration aucune quelque chose aux
pénétrations la vie 16
je m'emballe finalement normalement
le match est très normal
[Musique]
pas
baa
en
[Musique]
martin
m
picard
la caisse
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ce que par locales et s'il vous
plaît pour thierry ardisson ben alors
bonjour 6 à 10 ans que par locka lien il
a au nom par nom
oh
et
oui
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très beau c'est encore plus beau
qu'avant
de magnifiques lumières
mais m
m
c'est comment cette décoration du
palazzo lors des spéciales
on a fait comme si comme s'ils n'avaient
rien fait on a cédé père comme
constructeo lancé d'alerté traitera le
sucre ajouté rainer on remarque la table
et il avait bien trop nombreux titres
tous que des tissus comme un rideau à
akwa et cd dédié au théâtre est ici et
comme un temps que je vis ici mais si ça
fait dix ans de gens c'était quoi ce
lieu avant avance et un entrepôt
frigorifique et donc il est à l'époque
de là à l'époque de la guerre je crois
que ce serait pour mettre un peu les
audiences étaient comme la jccd depuis
qui a arrangé ça fait tout était déplacé
là bas et les trains arrivés il y avait
d'ailleurs même les wagons qui
arrivaient directement ici dans la bible
il y avait déjà des rats et même dans
les couloirs et donc la marchandise
arrivée sur des petits pas wagon
directement ici c'est pour ça qu'il est
laid les appartements sont en face à des
appartements mais les lieux sont assez
de fermer quand les gars de l'immeuble
de l'extérieur ça fait comme bruyère
plusieurs athlètes les fossés beau en
plus parce que quand on va chez toi et
qu'on regarde pas la fête on va voir je
vais t'ouvrir c'est étonnant ce convoi
par la fenêtre parce que d'un seul coup
c'est une complètement une autre cette
ambiance les gouttes et les chantiers ça
qui est beau c'est lé maroc et le côté
valait tout les futurs un peu des paris
de certains endroits en train de
construire la nouvelle station de métro
qui s'appelle météo
c'est ça qui donne un côté un peu new
york les uns j'aime bien parce qu'à ses
côtés un peu new york
mais ça c'est la dernière partie des
décors que j'ai fait cette espèce d'épée
téloche d'opéra là c'est drôle avec
l'exemple à 1 10 e et la 10 mois c'est
quoi cette locomotive qui est ici alors
un lot de pièces c'est un artiste qui
est mon voisin qui s'appelle jamais chef
jean-michel ploie qui lui à peine de son
travail d'artiste j'étais un travail
conceptuel et pendant cinq ans il a fait
toutes les démarches et d'aller en
pologne pour récupérer une locomotive
qui est servi gco pénale la guerre tu
vas pour
il va expliquer bien tu vas tout
simplement baissé plus que rigole à la
locomotive c'est toi là j ai hâte de
l'avoir fait
s'il a mené de pologne c'est ça et c'est
une info motif qu'ils savaient
transporter les gens dans les camps
c'est ça c'est une locomotive de guerre
et elle était en pologne
je lisais un truc le plus impressionnant
c'est l'odeur oui c'est vrai que en fait
il ya cette scénographie il voulait
centrer en premier
le visiteur lui quand le lieu est ouvert
au grand public commence par sentir
l'odeur c'est l'odeur et la deuxième
chose c'est que l'endroit étant
relativement exigu par rapport à l'objet
on est impressionné par la dimension de
l'objet c'est à dire qu'on ne comprend
que si on avait cinquante mètres de
recul on serait beaucoup moins
impressionnée par que là on voit la
locomotive comme devait l'avoir les gens
qu'on mettait dans le trap
alors ce qui est troublant aussi dense
sur cet objet c'est que elle a été
construit en économie guerre c'est à
dire qu'elle a été étudié pour couper le
moins cher possible être la plus
efficace possible avec la logique de
l'industrie allemande de l'époque et ils
ont créé cette espèce de monstre
c'est un monstre parce qu'en fait c'est
en quelque sorte un morceau d'une loutre
voilà alors les les roues ont été
peintes les bandeaux blancs des rouges
sont peints avec de la peinture
fluorescente et c'est un c'était
important pour moi parce que c'est parti
du de la réflexion sur l'objet sur
l'objet de l'histoire qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec un objet d'histoire
comment faire de cet objet une oeuvre
d'art par une intervention éphémère
puisque la fluorescence disparaît qu'il
ne reste pas de trace et par son
déplacement
[Musique]
moi c'est moi on savait très bien
comment ça les filles donc la mairie le
bouquin s'appelle comment un ruban noir
un ruban noir
petit clin d'oeil au ruban
qui pour moi est insupportable
et surtout les blousons et tous les
bombers de paris moi j'ai lu un papier
tout absolument insensé joker il en va
ces bacs rouge pendant 101 même moi
j'étais choqué
on sait rien dedans
je me suis beaucoup fonctionné pour nous
oui c'est vrai
dans les backrooms jusque là encore on
connaît
le retour de la nzf sexe si le retour du
sexe en ce moment il ya un truc quand
même c'est il ya
un côté romantisme
la mort tu vois un peu comme ça
si si si qui s'était passé au procès par
ipd
si j'ai un côté comme ça bon c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment pour être un petit peu à
la mode quand même beau métier beaucoup
plus excitant servez bien sûr dix mois
vincent qu'est ce qui te choque
je sais qu'il faut que je
le politiquement correct connaître
simplement on se quitte sur une
sérieusement c'est quoi
pas grand chose
le sida par m
parce qu'il faut qu'elle fasse peur
qu'elles fassent leur boulot après tout
une présence aussi jeu
dans ce qui me choque c'est pas grand
chose
je peux blindés cette idée de
et
l'esthétisme de la mort 2
de roulette russe de
si t'es pas un vrai pdc t'es pas sérieux
un peu
tout ça c'est pas quelque part c'est un
petit peu
c'est un peu idiot quand même je veux
dire c'est
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment le séropos
est en train de devenir un petit peu
un héros de la fin du siècle ils ont
fait le personnage de luxe on peut être
est ce une équipe européenne à enlever
c'est sûr et qu'il faut le demander
selon certains avocats américains ce
qu'on peut lire maintenant c'est zéro
coupe peut se permettre
dès qu'il est malade de
avec la médée
des framboises au mois de décembre et
puis d'abord tout le plaisir que lui ont
faites
la femme au sein du cimetière de la
courtisane phéniciens
c'est vrai qu'il sorte et qu'on veut pas
pareillement avec taurine
on sait qu'on peut pas tomber amoureuse
différents vos bâtons barres de toit
séropos c'est quand même un petit peu
ce pas quand est ce qu'il va mourir
doit faire le projet avec lui et tous et
c'est chiant quand même quoi
dû décliner c'est pas un objet d'avenir
c'est qu'on consomme consommation
instantanée consommation oui en même
temps c'est vrai que
dans une époque il ya tellement peu
d'avenir que me
et s'il veut pas faire alors il faut pas
déprimer ah ouais je pense que la
dépression et le premier
le premier facteur de
il veut casser la gueule assez
rapidement
le fait qu effectivement il ya ce qu'on
appelle le système hached a donc le
système génétique enfin ta mémoire génie
génétique qui fait que tu es plus ou
moins sensible que tu vas plus ou moins
développés
mais c'est vrai je pense que le fait de
se mettre dans une situation de mort
programmée à ses bouquets inversée
parquet 20 connexions appartement où tu
vas programme est énorme
vous l'imaginez sers tu dors tu as des
chances un peu facilité la chose
du reste on y va
[Musique]
madec
le monde
baguette chez yamaha
[Musique]
tout ce qui se passe puisqu'il ya
qu'est ce qui se passe et ce qui se
passe
de quoi
et 6 passes mais si tu
rien à vous dire pourquoi je travaille à
temps
qu'est-ce qui se passe
un d'accord sur l'heure aucun nom 1
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'était très
jours avant mais partie par
juste parce c'est un film est un vrai
mais qu'est ce qui a eu des séries
peu importe mais qu'est ce qui se passe
que se passe t il ont gazés tout le
monde
qu'est ce qui s'est passé présent gaz
à
[Musique]
mais
on est là
à celle du gaz
monter
la demande
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux